The first cook book was written by the Greeks
in 400 B.C.
In Quebec, there is an old law that states
margarine must be a different colour than
butter.
Chewing gum whilst peeling onions will prevent
you from crying.
There are eight different time zones in North
America.
In 1933, the animated, fictional cartoon character
Mickey Mouse received 800,000 fan letters.
Every 45 seconds, a house catches fire in
the United States.
Most burglaries happen above the first but
below the seventh floor in a hotel.
If you eat an excessive amount of carrots,
your skin will turn an orange-yellow colour.
The coldest object in our solar system is
not Pluto, it's Triton, one of Neptune's moons.
The oldest known goldfish was 41 years old.
In ancient Egypt, priests plucked every hair
from their bodies, including their eyebrows
and eyelashes.
To avoid sinking in quicksand, raise your
legs slowly and lie on your back, this will
distribute your weight evenly and stop you
from sinking.
The people of Israel consume more turkeys
per capita than any other country.
Flies jump backwards before they take off.
Roses are red.
But violets aren't blue, they're violet.
The clues in the name.